ينضم الينا الان قائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف احمد اهلا بك
معنا وشكرا لمنحك هذا الوقت لنا السؤال
الاول ربما هناك اتهامات موجهه من قبل
السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان لكم بانكم تسعون
للاستيلاء على السلطه ما ردكم على ذلك
في بلدنا العزيز
للقطاع البراق رجل الاعصاب
المجرم يعني
انا ما بتكلم في الموضوع
في الاتفاق الايطالي وثم الرافدين
ثم مباراه
التفاوض وتفاجات
كلها قناصين من الكتائب الجيش
يا سيدي حمدان سيد حمدان هو كثير من
الكلام نعم سيد محمد حمدان حميد اذا سمحت
لي كثير من الكلام الذي تقوله لا نسمعه
بشكل واضح يبدو هناك اشكاليه في الاتصال
اذا كان ممكن تحسين جوده الاتصال معك
واريد ان اعيد لك السؤال حتى نفهم منك
وجهه نظرك بشكل اوضح يعني هناك اتهام من
قبل البرهان لكم بان كل ما يجري الان هو
محاوله منكم للاستيلاء على السلطه فماذا
تقول في هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
الكتب
ثم الرباعيه
هم اللي ردوا على هذا الحديث
هذا الكلام
بناء على ماذا بناء لماذا تشير الى هؤلاء
بالذات
البلد وقعدنا معاه يوم السبت
مثلا
كلامه ده
بالنسبه للاوضاع الميدانيه اذا اردنا ان
نفهم الوضع في الميدان هناك
ادعاءات يمكن وصف الوضع في السودان لا
توجد معلومات مؤكده لدينا او اي احد
انتم وضعكم في الميدان هل حققتم اي شيء
كنتم تطمحون الي ماذا تريدون في الميدان
هل حققتم اي اهداف بالنسبه لكم
الان
يعني الحمد لله حياتنا
85% من المجرات
سيد البرهان في لقائه ايضا تحدث بانه لا
سيطره على مطار
الخرطوم انتم حرصتم في البدايه على
التواجد في مطار مروي ايضا من يسيطر على
المطارين الان
طيب
خط استراتيجي مرروا فيها طيارات
من الطيارات
ثم الرجال
استلم ملوي
ات من بره
صحيح منطقه سودانيه مهمه مهمه بالنسبه لنا
لكن اولويات
هناك حديث الان في البيت الابيض يتصاعد
وايضا مطالبات حتى من المشرعين الامريكيين
بفرض عقوبات على من يعرقل العمليه
السياسيه في السودان ماذا يعني ذلك لكم
ان شاء الله
وبانكم تسعون الى تطبيقه كيف يمكن لكم ان
تضمنوا الاستمرار في العمليه السياسيه رغم
انكم الان
تشاركون بشكل واضح في عمليات عسكريه كيف
يمكن
ان يكون من يحمل السلاح ضامنا لعمليه
سياسيه
يا اخي العزيز
قلت لك من قاتل الدفاع عن النفس
عشان نستسلم يعني
حتى برهان في الحركه الاسلاميه وعندنا
مجموعه بحركه الاسلاميه
جدتنا وطالبناهم من الجيش
اتكلمنا
الان البرهان كسرته الان البرهان وعن هذه
النقطه نعم سيد حميدتين هناك ايضا الطرف
الاخر يتحدث بان قوات الدعم السريع تعاني
فهم شباب على سيارات بيك اب يتحركون داخل
الخرطوم وفي مدن اخرى ولا توجد لهم بعد
ضرب مراكزهم لا يوجد لهم
موارد فيلجؤون حتى الى سرقات كما يتهمهم
الطرف الاخر
فلا تعتقد بان المشكله للطرفين هناك
اشكاليه ايضا في قوات الدعم السريع وعلى
القوات ايضا ضغط في ظل درجه الحراره عدم
وجود اماكن للايواء
فردك على هذه النقطه
كلها
موجوده هي ما موجوده عشان تقعد طبعا
سريع عنده بوكس
تويوتا انا
والذهاب الى الجيش
اي انسان يتجاوز حدوده
وعندنا قانون
مباشره الان
طوارئ مباشره وقدام ان شاء الله
قاعدين تعبانين
شكرا
كل اجرامهم كل قتلهم
القناصين
نفس القناصين الكلب
باذن الله شكرا جزيلا لك سيد محمد حمدان
قوات الدعم السريع